c'est aujourd'hui l'heure du verdict
c'est le jour où je vous donne mon
retour sur ce je lis parfois de là c'est
le samsung galaxy s 22 ultra alors c'est
toujours intéressant et je voulais déjà
dit donc plusieurs vidéos il ya déjà eu
une vidéo de présentation de ce
smartphone lorsque ça ne sonne pas
permis de le voir en avant première il
ya également une vidéo de des premières
images des premiers rendus qui ont été
faits j'ai tenté des choses voilà je
voulais dire publiés ça fait quelque
temps que je les j'ai pu également
partir avec samsung le tester en
condition de nuit pour voir ce qu'on
appellera la night aura fille et je vous
ai montré ça fonctionnait en condition
de nuit alors il ya des choses qui sont
pas parfaites a notamment sur la vidéo
la photo c'est bien il ya aussi
certaines limites mais aujourd'hui voilà
c'est l'heure de vous donner mon point
de vue global sur ce smartphone parce
que sans ces satanés pas moins de trois
nouveaux smartphones s 22 e s donne de
plus et le f-22 le trac est différent
l'année dernière on avait eu un s-21
ultra ya deux ans avait eu en as vu le
travail ça c'est super différent
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ce s22 ultra
il a fusionné avec samsung galaxy note
avec un stylet intégré donc c'est la
confirmation de la mort de la gamme
notre message lui ai déjà dit et puis
surtout ça apporte vraiment quelque
chose de l'ultra à dire c'est là où on
va le plus loin possible avec le maximum
de choses dont quoi faire le tour
complet on va regarder puis je vais vous
dire si au final ce samsung galaxy s 22
ultra ce qui me plaît ce qu'il me plaît
pas et ce qui me déçoit est ce qu'il est
bon photo est ce qu'il est bon vidéo est
ce que le nouveau processeur exynos 2002
sont en fait le taf à tout ça on regarde
maintenant
première chose à venir voir ici c'est le
format il est très atypique il est très
à part il est très massif il est très
grand regarder dans une poche de micro
tablier dans cette poche là ça prend de
la place ça déborde sur leurs gardes et
alors me direz-vous pas pire qu'un
iphone 13 pro mac ce qui lui va
également déborder donc là c'est un peu
le même style un vraiment donc ça se
ressemble énormément alors après il y en
a pour tout un chacun à chacun ses goûts
puis à vous de voir ce qui vous
conviendra mais c'est sûr qu'on a un
smartphone qui est hyper mastoc quand
même pour ça on enlève parce que c'est
pas le sujet du jour il est massif donc
ça à savoir déjà si vous aimez les
smartphones avec des grands écrans des
grandes diagonales qui sont assez massif
assez épais on va retrouver alors c'est
petit côté arrondi qui va ajouter un peu
de légèreté à l'histoire mais c'est bon
droite ça il vaut le savoir c'est le
premier truc est ce que vous aimez le
côté massif ou pas des heures dites le
moi maintenant bas en commentaire à
lorient n'est autre que je trouve
intéressant c'est l'ajout du spa lors
l'ajout du respect effectivement on se
dit tiens c'est un peu la fin de la
gamme mode voilà on peut retrouver un
petit spa noyon peut se faire des petits
jeux comme ça un peu à la hache voilà
j'ai perdu je suis nulle tant pis donc
on peut venir utiliser son espèce vous
avez l'air jester pour venir déclencher
des photos à distance pour dire comment
des remarques pouvait prendre des notes
commencer vos notes directement sur
votre smartphone de samsung grâce à
votre compte samsung ça monte dans le
club et ça va redescendre soit dans
votre galaxy book deux autres
ordinateurs votre pc de samsung soit
directement dans une galaxy tab et
suites sont ultra à vous de voir donc ça
c'est un autre sujet on en reparle aussi
très très très bientôt donc voyez ça
c'est super intéressant et je trouve ça
bien qu'ils aient mis le style ici pour
autant moi j'en ai pas l'usagé je vais
pas l'utiliser et s'il ya des personnes
qui aiment et qu'ils veulent ce stylet
et bien vous pouvez l'utiliser c'est pas
un point bloquant parce que si vous
voulez pas utiliser vous faites un truc
à vous faites comme moi vous laisser
planck est là et vous et touché plus ça
vous empêche pas d'avoir un très joli
smartphone un grand smartphone que vous
pouvez utiliser pour toutes les autres
fonctions à savoir de la photo de la
vidéo extrêmement facilement et ça ça
conviendra parfaitement bien lauriano
truc à voir avec ce format et ça je vous
le montrer c'est que ce smartphone il a
traîné un petit peu dans les poches et
il lui arrive et des petites déconvenues
à savoir que ben abdellah prix démarre
alors j'ai fait l'erreur dans
l'utilisant de ne pas mettre de coques
de protection et
numark et les jambes donc ça c'est un
truc auquel il faut faire vachement
gaffe puis ça me fait une transition
tout vu pour mon partenaire rhinochill
parce que je vous conseille réellement
devenir protéger votre smartphone parce
que même si vous avez des verre corning
gorilla glass effectué ce n'est pas
parfait ce n'est pas magique donc penser
vraiment à venir protéger votre
smartphone parce que oui info bien
protégés et vous avez plein de produits
pour venir le faire directement chez
rhino schild alors que vous invite à
venir jeter un petit coup d'oeil je mets
le lien directement en bas dans la
description puis tant qu'on y est vous
avez 5 % de remise avec le gode grevin
de ça c'est cool tout est en bas dans la
description aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil parce que c'est quand même
vachement vachement bien et puis à
regarder alors vous avez des coques de
protection pour un peu tout le monde et
notamment pour inception galaxy s 22h22
ultra alors si vous avez un iphone vous
pouvez également bien le protéger si
vous avez d'autres smartphones notamment
de xiaomi et compagnie pourrait venir
les protégés passons une gamme qui est
très très large et là on va regarder
pour le galaxy s on a le f-22 ultra et
pour l'ès 22 ultra vous avez les solides
suite des coqs qui vont venir protéger
votre smartphone un peu comme celle que
j'ai fabriqué pour moi là directement
sur mon iphone 13 promax et vous avez
plein de colère alors il ya aussi des
protections d'écran pour venir protéger
l'avant et des câbles on y re charge des
cas différents accessoires que je vous
invite à aller jeter un coup d'oeil ici
parce qu'ils ont plein de ce super mais
moi ce que j'aime beaucoup et bien sûr
les collaborations à prévenir vous
fabriquer directement ce que vous voulez
pas venir vous personnalisez votre coque
mais le truc qui est un peu qu'annonce
effectivement les collabos avec disney
avec marvel avec un plein de créateurs
directement ici sur le site de rhinau
chila leur gardien tout le monde vous
avez du spider man marvel league of
legends snoopy alors voir trop
effectivement mickey on a retrouvé le
quinze de france que vous avez plein
mohamed ali faisait one piece disney
classique star wars musée van gogh
marvel dragonball france rugby disney
pixar harry potter l'attaquent des
titans cnam une newsletter voilà si vous
la voulez pouvez la voir disney mickey
le mandalorien directement batman rama
il y en a des tonnes vous invite à venir
jeter un petit coup d'oeil directement
via le lien que je vous mets en bas d'un
description pour regarder trouver votre
bonheur directement sur le site de
rhinau chez vous ça fait quelques années
que je bosse avec rideau schielé savez
que j'ai vu grossir ce catalogue de
collaboration et s'étoffer énormément
avec aujourd'hui je dirais quasiment
tous sont des incontournables il peut
toujours y avoir d'autres mais ce qu'on
a ici c'est vachement qu'un autre donc
je pense que vous avez trouvé votre
bonheur une fois de plus le code grevin
2 pour acheter votre protection rhino
chic que ce soit à l'arrière avec une
solution que ce soit à l'avant avec une
protection d'écran ou alors pourquoi pas
des accessoires le lien est en bas dans
la description et merci à rhinochill
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo une fois
la protection mise et vous allez
protéger votre smartphone on peut
continuer à parler alors la première
chose qu'on va regarder effectivement
passé l'écran parce que c'est la
première chose qu'on voit c'est l'écran
de votre smartphone samsung sur metris
saidal je vous en ai déjà parlé j'ai pas
rentrer dans le côté technique de la
dalle et compagnie si les femmes il ya
plusieurs choses à venir obtenir c'est
une dalle zaki est extrêmement lumineuse
c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper l'umih et
donc si vous êtes un extérieur qui a
beaucoup de soleil vous lirez sans aucun
problème son vote dalle donc ça c'est le
premier point il faut vraiment savoir et
ça marche merveilleusement bien pour me
regarder du contenu multimédia que
netflix why you tube que ça que vous
voulez ça fonctionne alors j'ai déjà lu
ces quelques médias qui a vu des
problèmes au niveau de l'écran de mon
côté un mois dans mon test est
absolument aucun problème et l'écran est
vraiment d'excellente facture très
lumineux vers l'équilibré alors après on
devient effectivement dans ces
paramètres on ira gratouiller davantage
si on le souhaite et puis le paramétrer
en fonction de ses besoins en fonction
de sa vue le thème sombre également
parce que les gens voyaient car j'en ai
parlé je vous ai fait une vidéo pour
vous parler de 4 la fluidité des
mouvements c'est une dalle ltp haut
c'est à dire qu'on a un taux de
rafraîchissement variable entre 1 et 120
air sont d'ailleurs c'est important que
plus de fluidité mais servir taper dans
la batterie pour vous le laissez faire
le tapin vous mettez comme ça adaptatif
foyer et lui va faire le boulot il vous
choisira le taux d'actualisation
vraiment adapté à vos usages à un
instant t donc sert parfaitement bien
donc la ciotat une dalle qui est top
donc voilà je ne vais pas en dire
davantage vous avez un confort visuel si
vous le souhaitez pour me reposer vos
yeux vous avez différents modes de
l'écran vous avez le vie vous avez
naturel prévenir personnalisé bref une
fois de plus au plat samsung maîtrise
vraiment bien c'est d'aller là dessus il
ya absolument rien à raconter ça marche
du feu de dieu c'est génial mais voilà
on va arrêter on va passer un peu le
truc moi je me suis mis en full hd plus
histoire de pas venir consommer est trop
trop au niveau de la batterie et si vous
vous êtes un peu gourmands et gourmandes
et que vous voulez ce calme et où vous
mettez en wqs des plus mais ça va venir
bc l'autonomie et déjà que l'autonomie
c'est pas trop le fort de ce smartphone
alors effectivement une grosse batterie
de 5000 millions paire eur et ça
fonctionne là dessus j'ai pas rien lui
diront plus sur nos trucs qu'ils ont
fait cette année qui est vachement bien
c'est que il est compatible charge 45
crois donc c'est la première fois ça
s'est super bien sauf que vous n'avez
pas le bloc de charges incluent alors
c'est pas tout nouveau chez samsung me
direz vous mais comme là on
bob de charge de 25 crois qu'on pourrait
venir nationale commerce france parle de
45 kw est donc de toute façon il faut
venir le chercher bien l'acheter donc je
vous mets le lien dans la description
site vous intéresse achetez le
directement sur le store de samsung vous
allez pouvoir effectivement acheté votre
bol de charger votre smartphone mais
outre l'achat d'un smartphone à plus de
1000 euros ça me fait râler de devoir
acheter un bloc de charges en plus
j'aimerais bien en allant sur le site de
samsung mathieu je vous fais 50 % sur
votre blog des sharks si vous nous
prenez ce smartphone à plus de 1000
euros enfin ça serait ça serait cool
bref bon voilà je pas cette petite
partie par contre il se recharge
rapidement il est pratique il est beau
il n'y a pas de souci là dessus mais
c'est vrai que je m'attendrais avoir une
autonomie un peu plus fans voyaient
qu'un peu plus de développer un peu plus
lourd un peu plus conséquent j'en sais
rien bref parce que bien qu'on ait une
grosse batterie de 5 millions terreur
des fois je le trouve un peu voilà donc
c'est une journée journée une mission il
a cool on va pas au delà et je connais
sa trace mart folles qui ont des grosses
batteries de 5000 millan terreur mais
davantage dans l'entrée et le milieu de
gamme qui eux vont tenir un peu mieux
alors c'est parce qu'on n'a pas été
sollicité autant qu'on va solliciter son
samsung galaxy s 22 ultra peut-être que
j'ai tendance à plus jouer là dessus
parce que eh bien j'ai un smartphone
plus performant mais l'autonomie c'est
pas son fort bon c'est pas mal attention
ça marche je veux pas dire qu'il est pas
bon autonomie il ira mais ce que je vous
conseille réellement de bien faire et si
c'est venez acheter le bloc de charges
45 - sur le site de samsung parce que
comme ça la question d'autonomie elle
par un petit peu vous leur charge est
extrêmement rapidement et vous voyez que
ça laisse un peu vous le branchez vous
revenez un petit quart d'heure après et
vous êtes paix n'a pas de souci donc ça
ça efface un peu le truc ça ces trucs à
savoir alors puisque je vous parle de
performance il ya un sujet qui est aussi
super intéressant c'est la question de
la performance bah oui parce que cette
année samsung est arrivé avec un exil
aux 2200 c'est l'évolution de l'exercice
2005 est sorti années avant que tous les
exils hausse sauf que je sais pas si
vous le savez mais tous les ans samsung
sort deux versions une version exynos
pour l'europe et un peu le monde entier
puis une version un peu différente avec
un sandra gogniat certain dragon nuit
jian wang est sorti pour les états unis
pour le canada puis une petite partie de
l'asie donc ça c'est super sauf que nous
en réalité on n'a pas aujourd'hui le
processeur le plus performant et quand
j'ai vu arriver c'est inouï de 1200 je
me suis dit waouh cool parce que le gpu
par contre a l'air assez dingue parce
qu'un partenariat avec nvidia et nvidia
c'est quoi une vie diable va trouver des
cartes graphiques quand on est plein de
chance elle viable surtout nvidia est
vraiment connu pour le gaming dont je
vous dis ça y est le gaming sur
smartphone avec ce smartphone là ça va
nous emmener ailleurs on part dans un
autre nom dans une toute nouvelle
expérience et il serait temps d avoir un
truc complètement ou alors je veux pas
dire que c'est pas bien parce que ça
reste bien mais c'est pas aussi fou que
ce que j'aurais espéré et je reste un
peu sur ma faim là dessus ça m'embête un
peu parce que quand on nous promet un
truc on arrive on me regarde et nous
l'exil aux 2200 perdre une vie gars tu
dis à fait que qualcomm va faire un peu
la gueule banon font pas la gueule non
alors ça marche honnêtement pas faire
tourner plein de jeux je vais vous
montrer vous voyez pour venir jouer à
des jeux assez final fantasy 7 alors on
est vraiment sur un jeu d'arène hop là
ça fonctionne aucun souci là-dessus donc
c'est vrai que c'est fluide regarder je
peux bien me balader c'est extrêmement
fluide les animations sont fluides mais
la voyez j'ai eu un petit moment ça lag
et lorsque ça vient de ma connexion ou
pas je m'attendais à voir un truc
complètement fou en arrivant hop là et
on me disant ok on a un partenariat
qu'nvidia est alors autant ça marche
bien et j'ai pas de souci là-dessus je
peux dire que ça marche pas mais je
respire et un petit poil mieux donc
voilà il ya un côté où je reste un peu
sur ma faim et à côté de ça attention ne
me faites pas dire ce que je dis pas ça
marche il n'y a pas de souci on a un
truc qui fonctionne plus petite roulade
donc voilà ça fonctionnera mais bon moi
pas autant que ce que j'aurais pensé en
tout cas et puis un autre truc à venir
voir ainsi c'est toute la partie photo
vidéo qui est extrêmement importante
alors je vous demande des photos j'en ai
des tonnes de photos j'en ai pris pour
tellement mais je vous montre ce que ça
donne parce que je trouve vraiment bien
cet appareil en photo alors ça c'est un
peu la paix non ce thème et trop voyants
plein jour ça fonctionne vraiment bien
c'est net c'est bien c'est clair on a un
beau piqué bref ça marche très très bien
l' ultra grand angle et un peu moins
précis un peu moins de piquer mais c'est
normal c'est un ultra grand angle mais
pour autant il n'est pas déformant ça
marche bien ses droits c'est bien
maîtrisé donc ça ça fonctionne on peut
se rapprocher un peu et si on se
rapproche trop ça marche moins bien bon
alors c'est l'idée qu'on peut se
rapprocher quand même énormément donc là
je vous ai fait quelques petites photos
dans un montmartre pour vous puissiez
voir même au niveau des contre-jours
voyait il ya une très très très belle
gestion ans assez haut niveau la statue
du buste de dalida donc si vous voulez
la voir vous pouvez garder la séparait
toujours à montmartre un endroit plus de
couleurs un peu plus pêcher un peu plus
pétantes un peu plus saturé avec votre
grand temps qu avec l'ultra grand temps
qu'il ya un poil plus ternes mais pour
autant on regarde et on a bien l'oiseau
qui en plein vol là qui est net on a
bien les nuages la façade est très bien
je donne à moins de piqué on le voit
notamment ici sur les côtés mais parce
qu'après c'est de l'optique un plus on
se rapproche des côtes et aurait pas
endettée au lait sur un ultra grand
angle mais le voilà boulot dans
l'ensemble quand même très très très
bien fait la caméra de celle fille elle
est un peu en dessous quand même ça
c'est vraiment le truc je trouve un peu
plus terne et au niveau des po c'est pas
extraordinaire regarder on a tous le
traitement algorithmique et a cherché à
me compensés c'est pour ça qu ici on a
un peu plus de bruit au niveau du visage
et c'est moins bien mais alors je suis
mieux exposés face au soleil est bien le
résultat est vraiment bien voilà mais
bon après ça c'est algorithmique et
aujourd'hui tous les smartphones ou un
petit peu faire ça regardez là je vous
emmène à rome dans le panthéon ça
fonctionne bien alors on aura de
meilleurs résultats avec luttera
grand-angle parce qu'on n'y verra
davantage aidés notamment pour ses
bâtiments là on vient où mais bon ok je
vous passe un petit peu ça le panthéon
garder on a le plafond comme ça et là
l'ultra grand-angle prend tout son
intérêt
alors je passe très rapidement voiliers
sont bien trop zoom évidemment ça
fonctionne plus c'est pas très beau mais
pour autant je vais à l'extérieur j'ai
un truc qui marche bien le panthéon
comme ça est juste magnifique et ça
fonctionnera mais rennes on peut devenir
vraiment très très proches jusque là
c'est quand même plutôt bien là on sent
déjà que sally si on le voit quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup alors si on
va beaucoup plus près il ya un an ça
marche pas gardé même dans les églises
de l'intérieur ceux qui sont assez
dingue mais au niveau du zouglou
regarder je me rapproche et j'ai un
grand ducale qui est qui va chauffer ça
se voit que spies une fois sans même
s'il n'est pas parfait il est quand même
très impressionnant et pour venir chuté
en extérieur on a un truc qui est
vraiment bien sûr la nourriture aussi
c'est pas mal attention vous avez
différents modes assad sur un petit peu
je trouve un qui est un peu plus à
turenne et qui marchait aussi plutôt pas
mal ça c'était quoi ça c'est les
perroquets que j'essayais de shooter
avec le zoom x 100 on peut se rapprocher
choper des petits oiseaux si on le
souhaite voyez dans l'ensemble boulot
est vraiment bien fait bien maîtrisée
dans des conditions de belle luminosité
et là on arrive dans les conditions de
nuit alors ça je voulais montrer c'est
effectivement sur le shoot de nuit qu'on
ait dû faire le shooting de nuit avec
samsung leur caméra de celle fille
lorsque vous n'êtes pas beaucoup lumière
bras la plus de mal il faut de la
lumière de toute façon il faut bien
nourrir les regarder la connaissance de
sap de luminosité je suis con c'est
quand même vachement bien c'est pas
particulièrement bruitées ça
fonctionnera vraiment très très très
bien là on se rend pas compte mais c'est
vraiment extrêmement sombre et ça
ressort très bien très clair donc un
très très beau boulot algorithmique ici
en plus d'avoir des capteurs de bonne
qualité donc en conditions de faible
luminosité ça marche vraiment bien
pareil la condition de faible luminosité
on a un truc est vraiment cool luttera
vente angles en faible luminosité
commence à perdre un petit peu de sa
superbe et puis autre chose que je
voulais vous montrer ces fêtes photo a
été faite dans une pièce où il faisait
noir absolu on voyait rien et là on a un
rendu qui est dingue et ça marche
vraiment vraiment bien et ça permet de
voir tous crever au sol parce que je le
voyais pas regarder je vous montre une
vidéo qu'on a tourné au même endroit au
même moment pour vous rendre compte
qu'on n'y voyait absolument rien garder
cette photo la gelée prise en condition
de nuit noire on n'y voit rien et pour
autant le rendu est là et c'est
extrêmement bluffant pareil là on n'y
voyait rien du tout et on y voit alors
effectivement ça peut être aussi bien
que si on y voit en pleine journée mais
rendez vous compte cette photo là je ne
voyais rien je devinais un peu le cas
dit parce que j'avais un filet de
lumière qui venait de la lune mais je ne
voyais rien regardez je vous montre tout
de suite là quelques c'était quand
j'étais shooter avec elle à sept est roy
keane à une capture d'écran directement
l'écran du smartphone moment où il était
en train de faire cette vidéo avec une
expo longue et le résultat est vraiment
mais vraiment bluffant et c'est là où on
va tout la puissance et la performance
alors même si l exil aux 2200 il n'est
pas parfait pour une party gaming du
côté du gpu mais du côté du cpu ça
marche bien il ya un vrai travail qui a
été fait il m'a superbement bien grosse
capacité de calcul donc le rendu est
vraiment couleurs après on évite qu'on
s'est vraiment nuit noir noir noir n'a
une fois de plus je vous renvoie à la
vidéo de photos une vidéo en urbex que
j'ai fait avec samsung parce que ça vous
montrera vraiment ce qu'il en est en
condition de nuit et puis c'est pareil
en terme de vidéo je trouve qu'il est
vraiment bien alors il faut de la
lumière lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
lumière ça marchera très très bien dès
que vous en avez un peu moins fatalement
on s'en doutera ça va moins bien
fonctionné autant il arrivera sur des
poses longues et en bougeant pas posé
sur un pied en faire des trucs vraiment
exceptionnel en termes de photos nuit en
terme de vidéo c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce que ça va bouger pour
cela demandé plus de calculs et il aura
plus de mal donc il est vraiment bon
photo nuit en vidéo nuit c'est un peu
moins ça mais la vidéo normal elle est
bien c'est un smartphone qui est
stabilisée et qui je dirais et quand
même vraiment très très bon pour venir
ajouté que ce soit pour la photo et de
la vidéo il n'a rien à envier aux autres
si vous voulez un excellent photophone
et vidéo phone est bien le samsung
galaxy s 22 ultra il est vraiment top il
n'est pas autant parfait que ce que
j'aurais pu croire lorsque j'ai vu
l'annoncé mais pour autant je trouve
superbe très très bon en photo si vous
voulez un excellent photophone vous avez
un photophone qui est un peu passe
partout alors pas passe partout parce
qu'il fait un peu tout il le fait
moyennement bien il fait des choses
super bien et il le fait sur tous les
capteurs ultra grand-angle sera un peu
moins bons en photo nuit mais ça c'est
un ultra grand-angle et les ultra
grand-angle sont comme ça donc ça c'est
normal s'il est son ultra grand-angle et
tout le reste il est très très bon sur
les différents hommes sur la photo le
capteur principal ça fonctionnera on a
tout est hyper hyper complet sur la
photo de nuit il est vraiment excellent
donc on a un excellent photophone qui
fera un petit peu tout et qu'il le fera
très très bien sur la vidéo si ils
marchent plutôt bien franchement ça va
très très bien là dessus aussi pas de
soucis vous avez du wifi si ce que vous
avez de la 5g avait une certification il
pèse 68 vous avez du bluetooth 5.2 bref
vous avez tout ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
sur un smartphone de samsung du nfc pour
le paiement dématérialisé avec ça me
saoule pas google paie aussi sans
problème vous avez de l'ultra whiteboard
pour venir l'utiliser avec votre smart
tags plus et puis il ira très bien pour
l'écosystème de produits sa leçon donc
c'est un très joli produit ce samsung
galaxy s 22 ultra mais qui dit ultra ça
me paraît assez normal donc il en fait
beaucoup avec son espen moi l'espagne
j'utilise pas mais si vous avez besoin
d'un stylet pour la productivité bien
vous l'avez donc c'est un smartphone qui
est vraiment un mi chemin entre la photo
la productivité très grosse bête moi je
trouve plutôt chouette est plutôt bien
réussi j'aurais aimé elle est encore un
peu plus loin au niveau côté graphique
avec ce gpu signant parti d'eric nvidia
va ça ça me frustre à pau mais il est
déjà très très bien comme il est là et
je vous le dit j'avais noté le tarif il
est au tarif de 1 828 1259 euros et 12
156 1359 euros c'est un très joli
smartphone très très beau smartphone un
peu atypique 1 2 par le format et puis
le style aimé que je trouve vraiment
très très bon et puis surtout j'adore ce
design aussi au niveau du bugue photo de
ben moi j'aime beaucoup très bien réussi
il n'est pas aussi parfait que ce qu'on
a vu sur la fiche technique il ya
quelques petits points d'amélioration
leur attention il ya des mises à jour
qui arrive donc à des choses qui sont
probablement corriger et puis je pense
autonomie améliorée grâce à des mises à
jour donc là dessus je suis pas du tout
inquiet ça fera vraiment le taf il est
chouette il est beau il fonctionne bien
et il sent bon le sable chaud a vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez en bois en
commentaire moi je vous embrasse
n'oubliez pas de venir vous abonner pour
d'autres vidéos comme cela que ce petit
bouton rouge en dessous si les rouges si
vous n'êtes pas abonné penser à
actionner la cloche et aussi pour être
notifiée quand une prochaine vidéo
arrivera c'est sur ce je vous embrasse
[Musique]